khroma un minus journaliste spécialiste
du venezuela robin gusse bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors la
femme du député juan gouaille d'eau a
été escorté par des équipes
diplomatiques françaises néerlandaises
et roumaine venu la chercher à
l'aéroport de caracas on l'a vu est ce
que c'est bien le rôle de la diplomatie
française selon vous égoutter
sincèrement j'aimerais pouvoir vous
apporter une réponse sur le pourquoi la
diplomatie française se prête à ce genre
d'action je n'en ai pas je crois qu'il
faut plutôt demandé au quai d'orsay
néanmoins on a pu voir comme vous avez
comme vous l'avez dit donc une
l'ambassadeur de france alors soit
escorté madame fabiola rosales ou alors
lui prêter un service de covoiturage
pour la ramener chez elle
peu importe finalement rien ce qui s'est
passé quoi qu'il en soit pendant que la
diplomatie française fait une diplomatie
de type securitas ont blabla car les
entreprises françaises continuent à être
pénalisés par les sanctions des
etats-unis contre le venezuela au
venezuela et puis surtout la russie a
clairement repris le leadership dans le
dialogue entre l'opposition modérée et
le gouvernement bolivarien donc au
niveau économique et diplomatique
on ne cherchait très longtemps le bourg
boidin actions de notre diplomatie
réellement je n'ai absolument aucune
réponse à vous fournir alors diplomatie
également néerlandaise et roumaine est
là encore pourquoi ces pays là peut-être
une explication non lorsqu'il faut parce
qu'il faut voir aussi ce qu est ce qui
est ce qu'il faut noter surtout c'est
que ce n'est pas la première fois que
wang wei d'odense viol son interdiction
de sortie du territoire pour aller à d
show des tournées internationales
tournées internationales de précise dans
le but de renforcer les sanctions contre
le peuple vénézuélien
or il se trouve qu'en mars 2010neuf
c'est-à-dire il ya un an il y avait
beaucoup plus d'ambassadeurs européens
qui étaient venus l'accueillir donc même
sur le corps diplomatique qui est censé
le reconnaître soutenir wade est aussi
en perte de vitesse
alors on l'a vu juan jose haedo a été
également accueilli par des huées des
insultes comme traître assassin assez
des sanctions par les opposants à des
membres du corps diplomatique on lisait
ont dû l'escorter le climat au venezuela
il est de plus en plus hostiles pour
world wide haut alors depuis un an on
voit le why do vous l'avez mentionné
dans notre reportage d'introduction est
en chute libre la population qui le
soutenir les bus est complètement lasser
de ce personnage et notamment en raison
des scandales de corruption à répétition
de son entourage voire des biens qu'il
leur dit lui ses proches à des cartels
narcoparamilitaires colombien donc au
venezuela il est complètement discrédité
il est tellement discrédité qu'un groupe
de frondeurs d'opposition huard a dit le
perchoir de l'assemblée nationale
il y a quelques semaines c'était le but
donc ne cette tournée internationale
c'est à dire de ne pas paraître avec des
photos de chefs d'état et d'essayer de
redorer son blason au niveau national et
surtout de demander à un pays qui le
soutiennent de renforcer les sanctions
contre le peuple vénézuélien
figurez-vous que quelques jours avant
wang wei ne revienne au venezuela les
etats unis ont déclaré des sanctions
contre la compagnie aérienne publique du
venezuela clouant sa flotte au sol mais
ce sont les gens de cette entreprise qui
ont peur pour leur emploi à cause des
sanctions demandées par voie d'eau qui
sont venus lui faire un comité d'accueil
que nous
voir sur certaines vidéos qu'ils ont
absolument mais je pense aussi que le
retour à la réalité pourquoi n'y voyais
tôt après avoir été accueilli à l'elysée
à la maison blanche dans les
chancelleries d'europe ou d'amérique du
nord
retour à la réalité a été très dur parce
que personne ne le soutient
le meeting qu'il a donné quelques heures
après son arrivée ses deux nuls devant
400 personnes dire pour un leader
d'essence et changer le venezuela pour
un soi disant président d'euro proclamé
c'est un désastre bolides alors avant de
revenir sur sa tournée internationale on
en parlait tout à l'heure de la cote de
popularité droit noyés d'eau qui a chuté
passant de 63 % à 38,9 pour cent selon
le cabinet data analysis vous le vivier
alors roi de why do il n'a pas su
prendre son destin en main suffisamment
tôt qu'est ce qui s'est passé non il
s'est passé que le peuple vénézuélien
dans sa grande majorité ta chatte est
attaché à la constitution et aux
institutions de son pays n'a absolument
pas su lire wang wei tôt dans une
tentative de putsch institutionnel je
crois qu'il faut parler et utiliser les
mots tels qu'ils sont ce qu'il a fait
l'année dernière c'est une tentative de
putsch institutionnel
imaginons que n'importe de bienne
français s'autoproclame président de la
république française et on se lassera
soutenue par la russie la turquie l'iran
la chine l'afrique du sud
alors ça serait évidemment considérer
comme tel à une tentative de coup d'état
donc ça n'a pas marché et les gens comme
je voulais me sont lassés de cette
mascarade au venezuela est évidemment
ceux qui sont attachés à la constitution
et aux institutions de la république
bolivarienne du venezuela continue à le
a
revenons alors on en parlait son retour
faisait suite à une tournée
internationale de juan garrido il est
d'ailleurs passé à paris est ce que
cette tournée internationale à porter
ses fruits selon vous qu'est ce qu'on
peut en retenir cette tournée
internationale je voulais mentionner il
ya quelques minutes cédées surtout avec
un objectif national étant complètement
discréditée au sein de l'opposition anti
tsaristes que ça soit des citoyens qui
n'appuient pas la révolution
bolivarienne
mais aussi toute une grande frange de
politiciens qu'on veut plus entendre
parler de why do et de maduro non donc
la scène tournée internationale avait
pour but de montrer à ses partisans de
montrer à cette frange modérée de
l'opposition qui ne veut plus entendre
parler de tout et à répétition qu'il
était le leader donc monsieur boillon
s'est pris deux des belles photos avec
sa croix dirigeants du monde occidental
le retour au venezuela évidemment d'un
retour à une dure réalité
en revanche monsieur guido a demandé
partout où il est passé que les
sanctions soient augmentés contre le
peuple vénézuélien la sanction contre la
compagnie aérienne qui a eu lieu donc
compagnie aérienne publique ait lieu il
ya quatre jours en est une des mesures
et c'est ce qu'il a annoncé aussi la
maintenir la pression avec vos amis
internationale nous allons augmenter
faire augmenter les sanctions et ça le
peuple le peuple vénézuélien qui
souffrent de ces sanctions
il souffre 1 je rappelle quand même que
j'ai fait saxe l'économiste il n'est pas
un économiste progressif de gauche a
rappelé que les sanctions entre 2016 et
2018 avait fait 48 morts au venezuela
ça le peuple vénézuélien ne lui pardonne
pas merci beaucoup roma
je rappelle il vous est petit
journaliste spécialiste du venezuela